The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT Open Courseware
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ROBERT FIELD: So as I said at
the beginning of the course,
this is quantum mechanics for
use, not admiration, and not
historical.
You're going to leave
this course knowing
how to solve a very large number
of quantum mechanical problems.
Or if not to solve
it, to get insight
into how you would solve it.
And so I presented a couple
of exactly solved problems,
and that's not because they're
historically important.
It's because you're
going to use them,
and you're going to embed the
results of those exactly solved
problems in an approximate
approach to almost any problem.
And the vast
majority of problems
that you would face use
the harmonic oscillator
as the core of
your understanding
because almost all
potentials have a minimum,
and so that means
the first derivative
is zero at the minimum.
So you don't care about
the first derivative.
You care about where
the minimum is.
And the second derivative
is the dominant thing,
and that's the harmonic aspect.
And so using a harmonic
oscillator basis set,
you're going to be able
to attack every problem.
And another thing about
the harmonic oscillator
is that it uses these As and
A daggers, which are magic.
And what happens is
you forget, totally,
about the wave functions.
The wave functions
are there if you
want to calculate some kind
of probability amplitude
distribution, but you
never look at them
when you're solving the problem,
and that's a fantastic thing.
Now, there is one more
exactly solved problem
that I want to talk about
today, which is not usually
included in the list of
exactly solved problems
because it's kind of special.
The two-level problem.
The two-level problem
is exactly solved
because there are
only two levels,
and the solution of
that problem involves
the quadratic equation.
So there is an exact solution.
And this is used a lot in
introducing new techniques
in quantum mechanics,
and so you're
going to see the two-level
problem again and again
as opening the door
to being able to deal
with much more
complicated problems,
and I'm going to try
to refer to that a lot.
OK, so we're about to go
from the Schrodinger picture
to matrix mechanics,
and I'd like
to have some comments
about what are the elements
of the Schrodinger picture.
And there's no
wrong answer here,
but I'm looking
for certain things.
Anybody want to tell me?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is it based off wave
equation or the Schrodinger
equation, which is very
similar to the wave equation?
ROBERT FIELD: Yeah.
So we have a
differential equation,
and the solutions
are wave functions.
More?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ROBERT FIELD: Well, mathematics
is challenging to some people.
Some people really love it.
But yes, it's much
more mathematical
because you're faced with
solving differential equations,
coupled differential
equations, and you're
challenged with calculating
a lot of intervals,
and sometimes the intervals
are not over simple functions.
They're complicated.
But the main thing is you have
this thing which you could
never observe, but is somehow
the core of everything
that you can know,
and that really--
as I get older, it
bothers me more and more.
It's not that I'm going
to invent some way
to do quantum mechanics totally
without a wave function.
The most important
thing, I think,
is that when you work in
the Schrodinger picture,
you get one wave function
and one eigenvalue at a time.
And so yes, you can
solve these problems,
but no, you don't get insight.
You don't see the
overall structure.
You just see well, if
you did this experiment,
this is what you would observe.
That's perfectly wonderful.
And now, some anticipation.
What's so special about
the Heisenberg picture?
Or what is the
Heisenberg picture?
Now, I haven't lectured on it
so if you read my lecture notes,
you know the answers
to all of this,
but can we speculate
about what goes here?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ROBERT FIELD: OK,
so every operator
can be represented by a matrix,
and the elements of that matrix
are calculated
usually automatically.
Often, they're an infinite
number of basis states,
so you sort of refer to
the Schrodinger picture,
but anyway, these matrices
are arrays of numbers,
and they can be infinite
arrays of numbers,
but you don't write an
infinite array of numbers down.
You write a few numbers and you
recognize what the pattern is,
and usually, you have some
function of the quantum
numbers, and that generates all
the elements in this matrix.
And the solutions are going
to be certain eigenvectors,
and instead of differential
equations, it's linear algebra.
Now, for differential equations,
you'll learn a lot of tricks.
For integrals, you
learn a lot of tricks.
For linear algebra,
there aren't any tricks.
It's all right there.
And so it's a much
more transparent--
now, it might be numerically
demanding because you're
dealing with very large
arrays of numbers,
and you're trying to
get something from it,
but the linear
algebra is simple.
OK, and we have these things
called matrix elements.
I can use this word now
because the numbers in a matrix
are called matrix elements.
They're integrals,
but they're integrals
that are, more or
less, given to you.
And then we have
infinite matrices.
And in the Schrodinger picture,
we might have infinite basis
sets, but we don't
really think too much
about the problem of infinities
because we're looking
at things one at a time.
Here, the operators are
implicitly infinite,
and we have to do
something about that
because no computer can find
the eigenvalues and eigenvectors
of an infinite matrix.
So somehow, you
have to truncate it,
and you have to use
some approximations,
and the framework for that
is perturbation theory.
Now, I love perturbation theory.
I've made my career out
of perturbation theory
and you're going to see a
lot of it, but not today.
The next exam is going to have
a lot of perturbation theory.
OK, so let's review
where we've been.
With a two-level problem,
we have two energy levels,
and there is some
interaction between them,
and we get E plus, psi plus,
and E minus, psi minus.
So we have these
integrals, H2,2, H1,2,
and because it's a
Hermitian matrix,
it's equal to H2,1 star.
That's the definition
of a Hermitian matrix,
and that means if the
H1,2 element is imaginary,
the H2,1 matrix
element is imaginary,
but with the opposite sign.
Now, almost all of
the problems we're
going to face are expressed in
terms of real matrix elements,
and so all you're really doing
to go from the 1,2 to the 2,1
is just reversing the
order of the index.
Nothing else is happening,
and that has also
some great simplicity
in the solutions
we use to solve the
two-level problems.
OK, the solutions to
the two-level problem
are based on some
simplifications.
So what we do is we make
the two by two matrix
symmetric by subtracting
out the average energy.
We define then, two numbers,
which are H1,1 minus H2,2 over
two and this.
So we have E bar and delta,
and we have the interaction,
which is H1,2, and we call it
v. And we have to be a little
careful because v could
be complex or imaginary,
but for now, we're just going
to treat it always as real.
OK, so for this
two-level problem,
the energy levels are given by E
bar plus or minus delta squared
plus v-squared square root.
Or E bar plus or
minus the square root
of x, where that's x.
And the eigenfunctions
are expressed in terms
of these coefficients--
one plus or minus is equal
to 1/2 one plus or minus
delta over x to the
1/2 square root.
Square root is
outside the bracket.
And c2 plus or minus
looks almost the same,
except we have 1 minus or plus
delta over square root of x.
So in this reduced
picture, there's
not too much to remember.
The difference between the
eigenfunctions for the higher
energy and the lower
energy eigenstates
differ only by these signs.
OK, now, this is a lot.
I derived it in
lecture last time,
and the algebra is
horrible, and I'm not
good at presenting algebra,
but it's all in the notes.
But if you take these formulas
and you try them on for size,
you will be able to
verify that these
give normalized and orthogonal
eigenfunctions, which
I recommend, mostly.
OK, we take this expression
for the eigenvalues,
and let's just take one
of the eigenfunctions
and find out whether it belongs
to the correct eigenvalue.
If it doesn't, you've
made an algebraic mistake.
It's a very useful thing.
OK, so now we're going
to take the results
for this two-level problem
solved algebraically,
and at the core of that was
the quadratic energy formula.
The quadratic formula
for the equation
that determines the energy.
The quadratic formula
is always applicable.
It's exact.
So what we end up getting
is analytical expressions.
It doesn't matter what the value
of the two critical quantities,
delta and x, are.
You have solutions.
So now we're going to
take all this stuff
and we're going to start over.
We're going to rearrange it so
that we have a different way
of approaching the problem.
So we're going to start
talking about matrices
rather than operators.
And so I represent a
matrix by a boldface--
this symbol is how you ask
a computer to make it--
yes, it's how I represent
a matrix, instead of a hat,
which is the way you
represent an operator.
But now we're going to
say every operator is
represented by a matrix rather
than a differential operator.
And so this Hamiltonian is E
bar, zero, E bar plus delta, v,
v star, minus delta.
And v is usually real.
And another way
we can say this is
it's E bar times this fancy 1
with an under bar plus H bar.
So this is a symmetric
Hamiltonian matrix.
This is the unit matrix.
And now, since we're going to
be doing matrix multiplications,
let me just give
you some mnemonics.
So if we have a square matrix
multiplying a square matrix,
what we do is we multiply
this row by that column,
and we get one number, and you
fill out the square matrix.
And with a little practice,
this will be permanently
ingrained in your head.
We also can have a matrix
multiplying a vector.
And so a matrix multiplying
a vector gives a vector,
and this product
gives a number here.
And you've probably all
seen these sorts of things
or could grasp
them very quickly,
but it's useful just
to not get confused.
We can also do
something like this,
and again, we use the usual
vector and we get a vector.
I'm sorry, we get a column.
And this is a difficult
symbol to make on a computer,
but you get this first
element here like that.
And of course, you can
do this times that,
and you get a number.
And you can also do it
the other way around.
You can do this times that--
I'm sorry, don't do that.
And you get a square matrix.
So those are the things
that you have to practice,
and it becomes second
nature very quickly,
and it's a lot easier than
doing differential equations,
or matrices, or integrals.
OK, now, we use
this superscript.
This means transpose.
This means complex
conjugate and transpose.
The theory deals
with this, but when
the Hamiltonian or the matrix
you're interested in is real,
the transformation
that diagonalizes it
is always just given.
You need this to transpose.
So these two
symbols look similar
and you won't have
any trouble with that.
And now, we have
this kind of symbol.
So this is a normalization.
That should be
equal to one, and it
is because one times one is
one plus zero times zero.
And we can also look at
this, and that's zero
because zero times one is zero
and one times zero is zero.
So this is normalization,
this is orthogonality.
OK, we're playing with
numbers, and we don't really
look at the size, even
though the numbers all
are obtained by doing an
integral over the wave
functions and the operator,
but that's something
that you sort of do in first
grade of quantum mechanics,
and you forget how you
did it, and you just
know that they're there
to be played with.
OK, now, a unitary
operator is one
where the conjugate transpose--
the unitary matrix-- is equal
to the inverse, which means
t minus one times t equals one.
So it's nice to be able to
derive the inverse of a matrix.
And for certain
kinds of matrices,
this is really easy
because all you do
is tip along the main diagonal.
There are other matrices where
you have to do a lot of work,
but whenever you're
dealing with matrices,
you're not doing the work.
The computer is doing the work.
You teach the computer how
to do matrix operations,
and even if it's a hard one, the
computer says OK, here it is.
OK, so if you have a
real symmetric matrix,
then you can say OK,
T transpose matrix T
gives a1, a n, zero, zero.
So you can diagonalize
a real symmetric matrix
by this kind of
a transformation.
That's called an
orthogonal transformation.
And if it's not real,
then you use the conjugate
transpose, use the
dagger, and you still
get the diagonalization.
Now, in most of the
books that you'll ever
look at about unitary
transformations,
they actually are
giving you what's called
the orthogonal
transformation, and it's
what works for a real matrix,
and I'm going to do that too.
So when we have
something like this,
we say that this transformation
diagonalizes A, or H,
or whatever.
And the word "diagonalizes"
is really important
because that's what
you want because it
presents all the eigenvalues.
Remember, one of the things
about quantum mechanics
is you have an operator.
You're going to
observe something
connected with an operator.
The only things you can
get are the eigenvalues.
So here they are, all of them.
That's kind of useful.
OK, so in the
Heisenberg picture,
the key equation
is the Hamiltonian
as a matrix, some vector--
OK, this is the analog of
the Schrodinger equation,
but it's the
Heisenberg equation.
And mostly, it's just
notation, and you
have to get used to that.
We want to find the vectors
that are eigenvectors
of this Hamiltonian
with eigenvalue E.
It's just like this
the Schrodinger
equation, except it's now
looking for eigenvectors rather
than eigenfunctions
and eigenenergies.
Now, in order to
solve this problem,
we exploit this kind
of transformation,
and we insert T T dagger between
H and c, and that's just one.
So we don't even have to
worry about the other side.
We're just playing
with matrices,
but they look like functions or
variables, and everything is--
it's really neat how
beautiful linear algebra
is because you are now dealing
with an infinite number
of equations at once.
You're dealing
with these objects
and you're using your
insight from algebra
as much as possible in order
to figure out what's going on.
Really beautiful.
OK, and so now we must multiply
this equation on the left by T
dagger.
OK, I'm dropping
the under-bars now.
OK, so now we say OK,
here we have H twiddle,
and here we have c twiddle,
and here we have c twiddle.
So this is now a different
eigenvector equation,
but we insist that
this guy, H twiddle,
looks like E1, E2, En, 0,0.
A diagonal matrix, where
all the eigenvalues
are along the diagonal.
And so this is what we
want, and lo and behold,
this is what we need
in order to say,
well, yeah, this thing has to be
the eigenvector of this for one
of the eigenvalues because
this is an eigenvalue equation
or an eigenvector equation.
So if we can diagonalize
the Hamiltonian,
the transformation that
diagonalizes the Hamiltonian
gives you the linear
combination of basis vectors
that is the
eigenvector, and we'll
talk about this some more.
So for the two-level
problem, we want
to find E plus, 0, 0, E minus.
And usually, E plus is the
higher energy eigenvalue
than E minus.
Always, when you do this
stuff, you get eigenvalues
and you get eigenvectors.
And frequently, when you
do the algebra as opposed
to the computer
during the algebra,
you don't know that a
particular eigenvector
belongs to which eigenvalues.
So it's useful to have
a couple of things
that you normally insist on.
And so I like to
label these things
by plus and minus,
corresponding to which
is higher energy
and which is lower.
You could also say,
well, the plus is
going to correspond to a plus
linear combination somewhere,
but that's really dangerous.
So now, let's just
play a little bit.
So we have simplified
H magically so far
to diagonal form.
So H C twiddle--
I'm sorry, yes H C twiddle
is going to be E c twiddle.
So H c plus is going to be
E plus 0, 0, E minus, one,
zero because that gives
us E plus times one
and zero times one.
So multiply these two things.
We have a column vector, and
that's the same thing as E
plus times one, zero.
And we do the same
sort of thing to--
instead of using c
plus, we use c minus.
That's a zero, one, and that
will give us E minus times
zero, one.
This is all just
playing with notation
and we're about to
start doing some work.
OK, so T dagger times c is
supposedly equal to c plus.
OK, and so well, we
can write this formula
in a schematic way, and
so we have T dagger.
Now, I always remember
this because there
used to be something analogous
to Coke and Pepsi called Royal
Crown Cola, and for Royal
Crown, that just reminds me
that row first, column second.
I don't believe that any of you
have ever heard of Royal Crown,
but you could think of
some other mnemonic.
Now, it's really important to
keep the rows and the columns
straight.
So we have 1, 1, and T dagger.
Now, what goes here?
This is in the first
row, second column.
So what do I put here?
Yeah.
You could even say it.
OK, and here we
have T dagger 2,1,
and here we have T dagger 2,2.
Now, if we multiply one,
zero, because that's
what we're supposed to do here,
we'll get T 1,1 plus T 1,2
times zero, and then T
2,1 plus T 2,2 times zero.
OK, and that's simply
T 1,1 dagger times one,
zero plus T 2,1 dagger
times zero, one.
So this thing gives the linear
combination of the basis
vectors that is equal to
a particular eigenvector.
So that means if we can
find T, we can get T dagger,
and we can get E plus and E
minus, and c plus and c minus.
So we have completely solved the
problem if we know what T is.
Well, with a
two-level problem, we
know algebraically
that there is such a T,
and that it's
analytically determined.
There is another way of
approaching this, and that
is to say the general
orthogonal transformation,
which we will call a
unitary transformation,
but it's missing a
little bit of stuff
if it really wants
to be unitary.
I'm going to call it--
so T dagger is cos
theta, sin theta,
minus sin theta, cos theta.
So this is a matrix which is
determined by one thing, theta.
We want to find what
theta needs to be in order
to diagonalize the matrix.
Now, since we know we're
talking about sines and cosines,
and that there is one theta,
we abbreviate this to c, s,
minus s, c because the
algebra is heinous.
Not as bad as in the Schrodinger
picture, but it's terrible,
and so you want to compress the
symbols as much as possible.
OK, so we want T dagger HT
because that's H twiddle.
That's the thing we want,
and we want T dagger HT.
And now since we've
expressed the T in this form,
we can multiply this out.
And so we have c, c, minus
s, c, delta, v, v, delta.
Delta, v, v, minus
delta, c, minus s, s, c.
So we have three two by
two matrices to multiply.
Now, that's not something
you do in your head.
You could do two.
So you multiply these
two, and then you
multiply by that,
and the result--
I would be here for
hours doing this,
and you wouldn't learn anything
except that I'm a real klutz.
I should write this
on its own board
because it's really important.
So that matrix
becomes a big matrix,
c squared minus s squared
times delta plus 2sc times V,
and c squared minus s squared
times V minus 2cs delta.
And we have the same thing down
here, c squared minus s squared
times V minus 2cs times delta.
And the last one is minus
c squared minus s squared
times delta minus
2cs times V. So this
is what we get when we
take the general form
for the unitary
transformation, and transform
the Hamiltonian with it.
And the first thing
we do is we say,
well, we want this to be zero.
If this is zero, then
this is zero, right?
So this turns out to
be an equation that
tells us what theta has to be.
OK, and we also know
from trigonometry,
c squared minus s
squared is what?
I'm actually jumping ahead,
but it's just cosine two theta,
and 2sc is sine two theta.
So we're going to get a
simplification based on this,
but now let's just say
we want this to be zero.
So that means that c squared
minus s squared times V has
to be equal to 2cs times delta.
Which way am I going?
2cs over c squared minus
s squared is V over delta.
Well, that looks
pretty good, especially
because this is cosine--
this is sine two theta, and
this is cosine two theta, which
is tan theta is equal to this.
So now we have a
simple equation.
We have the theta, and
we have the V and a D--
a V over delta.
I shouldn't do that.
So now I can cover this again.
So we can take this
equation and solve it,
and we have that theta is equal
to 1/2 inverse tangent of V
over delta.
There it is.
That's an analytic result. So
for any value of V over delta,
we know what theta is.
That's not an
iterative solution.
That's complete analytical
result, and that's fantastic,
and it says, just like with
the quadratic formula, which
we used to look at the
original Hamiltonian
at the eigenvalues
of the original--
well, yeah, it says no matter
what, there is a solution,
and you can express
this solution
as some combination
of V and delta.
OK, and so when you do that, you
get that the energy levels are
E bar plus or minus delta times
cos two theta plus V times sin
two theta.
And there's no square root here.
Why do you know that?
Well, this is dimensionless.
This is the units
of energy, and so
square roots keep
coming popping up,
but you don't want
to put one here
because that would be wrong.
Even if you didn't
do the derivation,
if you saw a square
root here, you'd
know somebody is just writing
down things from memory
or copying badly, and
making corrections.
And that leads to E plus minus
is equal to E bar plus or minus
delta squared plus V squared,
and there is a square root
there.
This is what we derived
via the quadratic formula.
We knew this, and it
came out to be the same.
Well, it better have.
And we can also
determine what T is.
And I'm not going to write
it, it's in the notes.
It's a lot of symbols,
but it's something--
it's so compressed that
you can guess the form,
and so you should look at that.
We derived the eigenfunctions
of the Hamiltonian,
and they are exactly the
same as what we get here.
And remember that the column
of T dagger or T transpose
is eigenvector, and
sometimes we want
to know those eigenvectors.
We're doing semi-OK.
What happens if we go beyond
the two-level problem?
Well, you know from algebra that
there is no general solution
to a cubic equation.
There are some limited
range over which
there is an analytic
solution, but mostly, you
don't use a cubic formula
to solve the cubic equation.
You do some kind of iteration.
So for the number of
levels greater than two,
we know we're going to
have a problem because just
approaching it by transformation
theory or linear algebra as
opposed to the
Schrodinger picture--
if you can't get a solution
in one picture which
requires solving an
algebraic equation,
you're not going to
get it by playing
with these unitary matrices.
So we're going to be
approaching a problem where
we have to find the
eigenvalues and the elements
of the transformation
matrix in some sort
of computer-based way.
We're not going to do it.
It would be nuts, even
for a three by three.
Although, I will give
you an exam problem which
will be a three by
three, and you're
going to use perturbation
theory to solve it.
I haven't told you about
perturbation theory.
That's going to be next week,
but we're leading up to it.
OK, but now the point is we
have the machinery in place.
We have exactly solved problems,
and we have the key parameters
for exactly solved problems.
So the structural--
So for the harmonic
oscillator, we
have the force constant
and the reduced mass.
For the particle in the box, we
have the bottom of the box, v0,
and we have the
width of the box.
For the rigid rotor,
we're going to have
the reduced mass and we're
going to have the internuclear
distance.
There's things that
determine all of the energy
levels for exact
solved problems,
and they are basically
the things that
appear in the
Hamiltonian, and we call
them structural parameters.
And we have energy levels.
And often, these are some
function of a quantum number.
This is what we can observe.
We observe the energy
levels, and we represent them
by some formula,
and the coefficients
of the quantum numbers
relate to these things
that we really what.
So when you're not dealing with
an exactly solved problem--
like instead of having
a harmonic oscillator,
you have a harmonic oscillator
with something at the bottom,
or you have a particle in
a box with a slant bottom,
or you have a rigid rotor
where it's not rigid,
you have additional
terms in the Hamiltonian,
and they are going to-- we
are going to use perturbation
theory to relate the
numerical values of the things
we want to know to the
things we can observe,
and perturbation theory gives
us the formulas of the quantum
numbers, and tells us the
explicit relationships
of the coefficients of each
term in the quantum number
expression to the
things we want.
This is how we learn everything.
When we do spectroscopy, we
measure these energy levels,
and these energy levels
encode all of the structure
and all of the dynamics.
It's really neat.
OK, now, the last thing I
want to-- do I have time?
Yeah, maybe.
Remember when we do time
dependent quantum mechanics
with a time independent
Hamiltonian.
We want to have psi of x and t.
And usually, we're given
psi of x, t equals zero.
We're given the initial
state, and that initial state,
if this is an
interesting problem,
is not an eigenstate
of the Hamiltonian.
It's a linear combination
of eigenstates
of that Hamiltonian,
and the kinds of flux
we almost always use
to test our insight,
or actually, because they're
feasible experimentally,
is the initial state is one of
the eigenstates of an exactly
solved problem.
It's some special
combination of easy stuff.
And we need to know
how the coefficient--
this thing-- how that
is expressed as j
equals one to n of c j psi j.
Because if we can express
the t equals zero pluck
as a linear combination
of the eigenstates,
then it's just a matter
of mindless manipulation
because we have c j, e to the
minus i e j t over h bar times
j.
Bang, it's done.
So what we want to know is how
to go from a not-eigenstate
to an eigenstate.
And lo and behold,
that's just the inverse
of the transformation.
So what we want to know is
OK, since I don't have time
to spell it out
for you exactly, we
have t dagger, which
relates the zero order
states to the eigenstates.
We want to go in the
opposite direction.
We want the inverse
transformation.
So we want t, or we want to
take instead of the columns of t
dagger, we take the rows.
And so if you have a
machine or a brain--
and I'm not doubting this!--
that enables you to write down
all of the elements in the t
dagger matrix, you are armed
to go both from zero order
states to eigenstates,
and from plucks
to time evolving wave packets.
It's really
beautiful and simple.
And normally, when
it's presented,
these are presented as
separate project problems,
and the whole point is you've
got a unified picture that
enables you to go get whatever
you need in a simple way,
as long as a computer
is able to diagonalize
your critical matrices.
Well, I don't have time to
talk about this in any detail,
but if we look at the
eigenfunctions or eigenvectors
for the two-level problem, and
we do power series expansions
in theta, where
theta is V over d--
theta is also called
the mixing angle--
we discover that we
have some formulas which
says that the energy levels--
let's say the j-th energy
level is equal to E bar plus--
now I'm doing this and I have
to somehow grab something
from in here.
We have a sum of k
not equal to j of V--
of H.
This is the formula
for the correction
of the energy by a second
order perturbation theory,
and we can also write the
formula for the corrected wave
function.
By doing a power
series expansion
in terms of powers
of V/d or theta,
we find what the structure
has to be for the solutions
to the general problem
when n is not two.
I'll develop the formal theory
for non-degenerate perturbation
theory in Monday's lecture,
and that's really empowering.
It's really ugly, but
it gives you the answers
to essentially every
problem you will ever
face in quantum mechanics.
OK, have a nice weekend.